the history of civilization is one of
struggle against the disease virus
respects no borders that is why we have
attached great importance to
international health cooperation from
the outset children in the spirit of
openness and the transparency we
promptly notify the world about the
outbreak and shared the genetic sequence
of the virus we have been working
closely with wgo invited international
experts to join our ranks and provided
assistance and facilitation to foreign
nationals in China which to date
confirmed cases outside the China
account for less than 1% of the world's
total it means that China has
effectively curbed the spread of the
outbreak were beyond our borders for
that we have made extraordinary efforts
and a heavy sacrifice for global public
health security
that's that china is not fighting alone
the international community has given us
valuable moral and material support this
joint fight is strengthening the
friendship between the Chinese people
and people's across the world Russia
Belarus and the iokay swiftly delivered
badly needed medical supplies to hand
through chartered flights Pakistan
ironclad frother centers virtually all
the mosques in his stock at the peak of
the outbreak
Prime Minister Hansen of Cambodia paid a
special visit to Beijing to offer his
staunch support for China through a
specially made video Prime Minister
Prayuth chan-ocha of Thailand conveyed
the message that Thailand and China are
one family committed to fight the
epidemic together
Prime Minister Mahinda Rajapaksa Sri
Lanka prayed for China Eddy of a rama
temple in colombo alongside nearly a
million Buddhists in his country
it held him president sergio mattarella
visited a school with a large number of
Chinese students and hosted a calm
in the kirino palace in support of China
in the toughest times of the fight
people around the world are standing
firmly by our side
Japanese groups sent assistance supplies
to China attached with ancient Chinese
poetic lies fear not the want of armor
for mine is also yours to wear
attachment message of empathy from a
close neighbor in other parts of the
world Americans from all walks of life
donated medical supplies an Indonesian
policeman sent a song go Wuhan you okay
pupils performed a Chinese song fill the
world with love the Bush Khalifa tower
in the UAE was lit happy red in support
of China and from this country and from
this city Bayern Munich sent his best
wishes to China in the face of danger
Philipp playing a French doctor working
in Wuhan did not hesitate to stay and
fought alongside the Chinese people he
said he kept a bottle of champagne to be
popped open for celebrating the end of
the epidemic Maya Renzi jewelry is in
bad way students who lived in Wuhan for
three years also chose to stay and
signed up to be a volunteer to date
leaders of more than 160 countries and
international organizations have sent
letters or messages to express their
firm support political leaders around
the world have spoken in public to cheer
for Luhan and a cheer for China the
Chinese nation is a grateful nation we
will remember and hold dear every
absence of support on behalf of the
Chinese government let me say a
heartfelt thank you to all the countries
international organizations and people
who have supported China's ongoing fight
against the epidemic ladies and
gentlemen this sudden outbreak reminds
us once again
we live in a time when traditional and
non-traditional security issues are
entwined and when local issues easily go
global and vice-versa
no country can prosper in isolation or
meet all challenges on its own as our
interests are so closely integrated
Munich security port 2020 restlessness
reflects a perception of the world among
some in Europe and the United States but
China's view is that as human society
has entered at the age of civilization
warmer we must transcend the east-west
divergence and the north-south divide to
see our shared planet as a community
culture for all must go beyond the
ideological gap and accommodate
historical and cultural differences to
see the international community as one
global family in the era of
globalization always faced the same
challenges we showed her common
responsibilities and we have a shared
future this means we must set up an
effective framework for multilateral
cooperation to jointly tackle the myriad
of challenges it also points to the need
for committing to multilateral
cooperation whereby international
affairs are truly discussed and decided
by all involved many countries have
proposed constructive ideas on building
multilateralism as President Xi pointed
out in promoting and enforcing
multilateralism our aim should be to
safeguard peace and development for all
and uphold fairness justice and mutual
benefit and the practice of
multilateralism should be grounded in on
international law and widely recognized
norms of international relations this is
China's
considered answer to the question of how
to put multilateralism into action in a
globalized world first to uphold multi
we should pursue shared development
multilateralism does not stand for
putting any country above others instead
it advocates the equal right to
development shared by all countries if
the west enjoy lasting prosperity in
progress while the rest are mired in
backwardness multilateralism can never
be fully implemented and the common
progress of humanity would be impossible
to achieve face at home a renowned
Chinese sociologist envisioned a world
in which countries treasure their own
values appreciate other cultures and
promote shared prosperity in the
globalized era only when more countries
get to develop can the international
community be empowered and can there be
more partners in our joint response to
challenges as a big country with 5,000
years of civilization in China's
modernization which is being achieved
through the hard work and wisdom of its
people represents an inevitable trend of
history given its national conditions
China will not copy the Western model
were given as cultural traditions Lord
China will not seek hegemony even when
it grows in strength what we have chosen
is peaceful development of our own
country and mutually beneficial
cooperation with the world having led to
remark or success the path of socialism
with Chinese characteristics is brimming
with vitality and embracing an even more
promising future the Communist Party of
China represents the fundamental
interest of all China's people and its
leadership is supported by the 1.4
billion people of China China respects
the choices of Western countries and
will draw on the experience of developed
countries to work for shared prosperity
likewise the West also needs to is true
the subconscious believe in the
superiority of eight civilization
function and abandon is prejudices and
anxieties regarding China it needs to
respect the choices of the Chinese
people
welcome the development and rejuvenation
of a major country in the east one with
the system different from the West for
China's development and rejuvenation is
an important part of human progress and
ladye embodies the colorful diversity
brought by multilateralism second to
uphold multilateralism major countries
should set a good example collaboration
between major countries is instrumental
to the success of multilateralism in
international and particularly in
multilateral affairs major countries
played a key role and show their
significant responsibilities therefore
they need to behave in a way that is
consistent with their status instead of
putting their own interests above those
of others they should care for the
common interest of all countries instead
of carving out its fears of influence
they should work for an open world
instead of provoking confrontation they
should work together to maintain world
peace and stability china will further
strengthen strategic coordination with
russia following the strategic guidance
of our president we will advance our
comprehensive strategic partnership of
coordination for new era on all fronts
and is still more positive energy into
global security stability and strategic
balance china will work with the u.s. to
find a way of promoting peaceful
coexistence a mutually beneficial
cooperation we hope the US side will
embrace a more open and inclusive
approach when viewing China's
development will work with us to manage
differences in a spirit of equality and
mutual respect
adhere to the principles of coordination
cooperation and stability in bilateral
ties we should work together to keep
china-us relations along the right track
China will deepen cooperation with
Europe across the board with a focus on
upgrading China EU relations enhancing
cooperation on Korean development and
the digital economy and expanding China
central Eastern European country
cooperation in two more fields as always
we support Europe
integration we support a united and
strong Europe and we support Europe's
active role in multilateral affairs
third to uphold multilateralism we
should uphold international norms
multilateralism is untypical so
unilateral moves instead it supports
greater democracy in international
relations based on international rule of
law and justice the principles enshrined
in the UN Charter including respect for
national sovereignty peaceful resolution
of disputes are not interference in
internal affairs are the bedrock of
modern international law as the first
founding member of the UN to sign its
Charter China has stayed true to the
UN's founding aspirations and firmly
defended the purposes of the Charter and
international law proceedings from our
commitment to national sovereignty China
has caught for a syrian-led a Syrian
owned approach for Syria and an
afghan-led afghan-owned solution for the
Afghan issue proceeding from our
commitment to non interference China has
rejected unwarranted interference in its
internal affairs on issues related to
Taiwan Hong Kong and Shenzhen
under post the power politics of
meddling in other countries internal
affairs
proceeding from our commitment to the
peaceful settlement of disputes China
has advocated a negotiated solution to
the Korean Peninsula nuclear issue based
on the simultaneous achievement of
complete denuclearization and a lasting
peace mechanism in the same spirit we
endeavour to settle disputes in the
South China Sea through dialogue and
negotiation and are working with ASEAN
countries on a code of conduct to be
observed by all relevant parties
seating from our commitment to
international fairness and justice china
has firmly stood with the Palestinian
people each and all the oppressed people
in their call for justice we opposed the
strong bullying the weak the Vega
bullying the small and unilateral
sanctions or long arm jurisdiction which
find no ground in international law we
provided assistance to fellow developing
countries to the best of our ability and
without any of the little strings
attached and advanced south-south
cooperation the mission of China's
foreign policy is to promote world peace
and common development it is rooted in
international law which the basic norms
governing international relations and
will not be swayed by turns of events we
pursue no selfish interests our policy
which is stable and consistent can stand
the test of history and has won the
trust of others the fourth to uphold
multilateralism we need to see the world
as one community the outbreak of the
epidemic has once again reminded us that
our futures are closely linked global
governance and international
coordination must be strengthened
without any delay on this front
President Xi important forward an
important initiative of building a
community with a shared future for
mankind calling on all countries to rise
above differences in social system
history culture and development stage
jointly preserve mother earth our common
home and work for prosperous global
village in which we all have a stake
through the initiative of building a
community with a shared future is
inspired by the traditional Chinese
philosophy that sees the world as one
big family it reflects for found
thinking on the future of mankind
anybody's a spirit of humanity it points
the way forward for global governance
and represents the ultimate goal of
intellectualism it is a Chinese proposal
on how to address today's challenges it
has become an overarching goal of our
major country diplomacy with Chinese
characteristics China who is ready to
work with
countries and make unremitting efforts
to this end thank you
[Applause]